title of this talk is Python and Johnny
Cash the subtitle is that programming is
or can be subversive we're at PI data
London it's Saturday May 17 2016 so
hello I'm James Powell he say hi James I
appreciate that for those of you who are
lovers of Johnny Cash you know that he
started many of his concerts with hello
I'm Johnny Cash and he'd go straight
into fulsome Street Blues or sorry
Folsom Prison Blues for me I would say
that Python is something of an
occupation and a hobby I do get paid
money to write Python code although the
Python code that I write for work is not
quite what I show you in these
presentations I do spend a lot of my
free time writing code for fun to
explore new ideas I find that writing
code and especially writing Python is
something that can be very enjoyable
it's very fun for me it's exciting it's
thrilling I get to explore new worlds
and new ideas and new thoughts I like
programming and I like programming in
Python because it's an opportunity for
me to find a balance between following
and breaking rules between ignoring the
rules and bending the rules and figuring
out what can get what you can do that
people tell you you shouldn't or camp
too many of the presentations that I've
given previously at events like this are
were the result of somebody telling me
no you can't really do that in Python or
you shouldn't do that in Python and me
wanting to prove them wrong
in this sense I could say that I like
the subversive side of Python and I like
the subversive side of programming in
general I would say that the outside of
their costume that I'm wearing here we
all know that Johnny Cash was the man in
black I probably am the most
subversively dressed person here after
all
I'm a guy in a suit at a programming
conference I actually think that Python
is a very subversive language if you
think about it I do a lot of corporate
training and one of the
call-and-response I do in corporate
training is I ask the class is Python a
serious and grownup language and I don't
think it is I think Python is a silly
and fun language it's full of Easter
eggs it's made to be enjoyed but then I
asked them is Python a language which
can do serious and grown-up things
and while it's a silly and fun language
you can do very
serious work with Python here in this
presentation at the end of the day I'm
going to show you something that the
more I look at it the more serious work
I see can be done with it
there's actually a set piece for this
entire talk and when I was putting the
set piece together late last night I
found that I didn't feel it was
compelling enough to present it to you
by itself so there's a little bit of
additional meetup now I will tell you
that the title of this talk was a joke
the title of this joke was a talk when
preparing my talk for this event I
couldn't figure out a title and I
couldn't figure out exactly the angle I
wanted to tackle I asked the executive
director of Numb focus Leah silen who I
hope you all have an opportunity to
speak to sometime during this weekend
please take the time to thank her for
all of her tireless work and for all of
the work put on buying them focus to
make this event possible she's a fan of
Johnny Cash in fact she might not tell
you this but she shares a birthday with
Johnny Cash this is why every year I
have forgotten her birthday and she put
me on the spot so let's see if we can
make it work
so I do apology I do apologize to fans
of analogies it's gonna get a little
strained in here but we can also have
some fun it is the end of the day so for
those of you who who here doesn't know
who Johnny Cash's who hears it too
embarrassed to admit they don't know who
Johnny Cash's okay a couple of people
he's a very famous American I'd say
country musician he was actually a
singer-songwriter when I play some of
the songs for you I think you'll
recognize them in fact let me start off
with one song by Johnny Cash one of his
most famous songs a song I've been
humming all day which is I walked a line
and you can see that this talk may walk
the line between good taste and bad
taste between our meaningful analogy and
a strained analogy but nevertheless
we'll play a little bit of Johnny Cash
for you
who has never heard this song will
convert you by the end who's never seen
somebody play mplayer through an ipython
notebook isn't that frin that bizarre
very good so one thing that we know one
way that we walk the line in Python is
we're encouraged in Python to do things
like monkey-patching and we've all seen
some instances of monkey-patching
you know one very preposterous example
that every first every beginner Python
person tries is they see there's a
function called Len they can pass in a
list with three elements and they say
wait a moment you know I can / I can
override / overload override all sorts
of functions maybe I could override lens
so I could write something like this and
I could say well instead of returning
the length of an object return the
length plus one that'll really make my
co-workers pause for a second if not
outright hate me and then when you call
it on one two three suddenly you get a
result that you completely don't expect
me to say wow this is a very powerful
language in previous versions of Python
this talk is given in Python 3 but in
Python 2 you could do things like say
true/false equals false true and all
sorts of absurdities it turns out that
these kind of monkey-patching is a
clever technique but especially when it
comes to the monkey-patching of
built-ins it's not actually particularly
useful it is however useful in
illustrating to us one of the reasons
why Python is so flexible which is a
Python has a very rich runtime when
contrasting Python with a language like
C C++ or Java one of the major things
that we see is that Python is almost
entirely runtime with only a very small
component that you might consider to be
a compile time people often complain
that Python has no compile time checks
that's not quite correct Python has
checks at least for a grammar make sure
the parser makes sure that there's no
parser errors and that occurs something
that you can consider compile time
there's a couple of other texts that you
could you could you could do at parser
time if you're a fan of vim plugins
likes antastic you can do name checks at
something akin to compile time to make
sure there are no named errors but
outside of that almost everything occurs
at runtime this makes for an incredible
fixable language where you can do a lot
of neat things one thing that we see is
that python is full of I wouldn't say
exploitations of its rich runtime but
practical applications of what you could
do if you had a rich runtime so for
every intermediate Python user you
probably stumbled across a module like
inspect you said this is really neat I
can use the inspect module to do things
like view the source code for a given
function I can figure out where a
function comes from I couldn't really do
that in C because a function doesn't
exist at runtime and C it's just a bunch
of assembly instructions plus maybe some
dwarf debugging information but there's
no concrete entity at runtime to
represent this whereas in Python I can
do all sorts of neat things in fact in
Python I can actually look at my stack I
can get the current frame for the
function I can look at the outer frames
and you can kind of do this in C and C++
with libraries like Lib unwind but the
compiler could easily eliminate stack
frames or easily perform some
optimization that would obscure your
view of what's happening whereas in
Python it's easy we have some function
called G we have some function called F
when we call when we call F it calls G
inside we can use get we can use current
frame and get outer frames to peek into
the frame of our caller and to look at
variables and to you know in the
previous example you can see we had this
X variable it was 1 2 3 we printed it
out they printed out 1 2 3
inside G we can look up one frame mutate
X and we get a totally different result
and this is something that people
wouldn't expect and in fact this
technique is probably even more obscure
than our basic monkey patching I will
say that I have used this technique as a
as a very very last-minute last-ditch
effort at fixing a system very late at
night where I want to do something
incredibly surgically that I knew I
would I knew that if I woke up in the
morning I would go fix it and if I
didn't then what can you do I died a
happy man now one interesting thing is
this breaks in account in a couple of a
couple of weird ways this won't work
with
value types it's an exercise to read or
why this doesn't work with value types
the reason is that the local scope is
shadowed by fast locals but it's not
that important what we can see is that
we have a very rich runtime in Python
and we can use it for other things if
you look in the SIS model might be the
next place you go you see things like
set trace and set profile and you can
set functions that get called every time
a Python function gets called
here's a simple trace that just prints
out you know every time this tracing
function gets called and you can see
when you run in the ipython notebook it
sure is an awful lot of function calls
to do not a whole lot of work in fact if
I just do x equals 10
it sure is an awful lot of function
calls just to get this x equals 10 to
evaluate my ipython notebook you can see
we have triggered some code hooked on
every execution according to the Python
interpreter for where the tracing
function should run before we continue
with the presentation of course we have
to turn this off because otherwise it
will completely blow up our notebook the
other thing that we can see is we can
there are some explicit places where we
have hooks in Python in fact if we think
of Python as a language that emerged
from a lot of people who had been
writing systems in C C++ and Java for
many years finding common patterns in
that and realizing that in large mature
systems we always need some safety valve
some hook to address maybe one issue
that got missed in design or to work
around some patch or two sorry to work
around some small issue to patch some
small thing well we might designer what
safety address if you look at physical
construction physical instruction is
full of these safety valves these escape
hatches ways to make sure that if
there's a mistake in the original design
you can account for it and an example of
that would be sis top meta path you can
add import hooks in Python so here's a
simple example this is a simple import
hook if the user accidentally misspelled
math or random when trying to import
these modules it corrects that for them
and it's a very simple thing we hook
into the import system whenever you try
and import a module we run our custom
code it's not particularly interesting
you can see I accidentally misspelled a
math module and I get the right thing
I accidentally misspelled a random
module and I get the right thing this
can actually be used for some very
effective thing
you can see that not Pat not Metta path
but path looks are actually used in some
very large organizations in order to
store all the source code in some sort
of object database and to load it real
time so that you never have to
distribute source code to your users we
have some other mechanism the
application only has a very small stub
that will then automatically load all
the source code as needed you can also
do some neat things and this is
something that I prototype for somebody
they were refactoring their codebase
they wanted to move some modules they
wanted to change the names of some
modules and I told them in about 20
minutes and a I'd say about 40 50 lines
of code I could write you a really
simple import hook that you could rename
modules so here you can see that if you
have a module called moth you can rename
it to math and you can even put
expiration dates on it it'll trigger
exceptions or warnings to tell you hold
on a second stop using that old name you
can start using the new name and this is
getting more and more useful and when
you have access to all these techniques
especially if you come from the
background of being a C or C++ developer
you kind of feel good about yourself you
can do a lot of really neat things that
would otherwise be completely impossible
in the very static world of C in fact
from the perspective of a Python
developer there really isn't much to a C
runtime 3 there's much going on we will
later on notice that that is not at all
correct and so you might feel a little
bit of Pride and you might turn on your
radio and listen to them Johnny Cash and
one of his other most famous songs
so you'll know it's me and I come
through your codebase and that's how you
will feel about Python after I touch
your codebase
we'll do some things that might be a
little bit questionable but overall
there'll be some net benefit we'll make
use of all these safety valves all these
escape hatches to really make sure that
the system can operate as large systems
do but let's go a little bit deeper
now one misconception that we might have
about languages that aren't Python is
that they don't have the ability to do
any of this that C doesn't really have a
runtime then you can't do anything at
all
to patch a C program but that's not
quite correct in fact I had a real-world
example of this very recently it turns
out I was using I wanted to display this
little clock applet on my desktop and
the clock applet was provided by plasma
which is a new name for the KDE desktop
environment every time I launch the
clock applet it would crash my window
manager I have to read have to restart
my window manager or forcibly shut down
Y deep in the code well how did I find
this out well I I noticed at the
terminal when I'd run this application
it would say terminating current
notification service with pit so I
gripped for that in the source code for
the plasma applets and I found this is
the one line with that string and one
line below you can see they're calling
kill on a process ID there accidentally
killing the wrong process is this a
mistake I don't really know I don't know
the plasma toolkit well enough I'm
probably not using it in the way that
it's intended to be used I'm trying to
use it with my own window manager maybe
you're not supposed to do that I'm not
sure one thing that I could do is I
could elect to I have the source code I
could just build my own version of this
but I don't really want to do that
because then I'll cut myself off from
updates I'd really rather find a more
surgical way to patch this well this
turns out to be something that's very
easy to patch in the world of see what
we can think is that this applet this
application has some code that was
written for that application when that
application was compiled the code that
was written for that application was
turned into assembly code
parts of that application that came from
libraries such as the kill function
which comes from a library for handling
signals
we're not statically compiled into the
executable why should they be in fact we
decide we really want to have shared
libraries because maybe that kill
function has a bug in it or so some
security flaw in it so you want to be
able to update that without having to
recompile all of our software that I'm
to download everything again so what our
application has to do assess that
dynamically bind to this kill see it
turns out that whenever you start a C
application or a C++ application there's
a process called dynamic linking and
what the dynamic linker says is tell me
all the symbols that contain that
reference code that you don't personally
implement that are implementing some
library and I'll match them up I'll make
sure that when you call kill it'll
actually call a source code provided by
your signals library part of your C
standard library that implements that
and it turns out that you can interpose
that you can interrupt this process very
easily does anybody know how you do that
LD preload so it turns out that you can
write what's called an LD preload it's a
very easy thing to do when your dynamic
linker runs it looks for a special
environmental variable that
environmental variable is called LD
preload it should contain the path to a
shared object a small C program that
you've written that doesn't contain a
main that's just a shared library what
it'll do is if that little shared object
has any symbols in it like a symbol
referencing a function called kill it'll
first bind to that kill rather than the
kill in the standard library so here's a
simple this is what I did in order to
solve the problem
I wrote a simple little LD preload I
implemented my own version of kill if
you tried to send sig term I would just
say no don't bother don't do it
otherwise I would call the real kill
function and pass it along so if my
little clock a blip my little plasma
applet try to call kill with an int
signal or a hop signal or something like
that we just happily pass through if it
tried to terminate a process which is
the behavior I wanted to stop or we get
trapped by my interposing function
something very similar to monkey
patching that we see in Python you
see this turned out to be pretty easy to
do but as the complexity of these things
grows actually becomes much harder to
write LD preload LD preloads are a real
pain to write because you have to write
them and see and as Python programmers
we're not used to the more shall I say
demanding and unforgiving nature of
programming that we have in C language
and the way that we use this is instead
of running our program we just run our
program with an environmental variable
we give it the name of the shared object
and all the symbols in the shared object
will take preference over something else
so you can see we already have a little
bit out of dynamic nature and see but it
turns out that this is not a very
pleasant way to modify your programs in
fact it's very unpleasant to do you have
to write a lot of C there's a lot of
boilerplate a lot of pointers you have
to deal with
it's really quite unpleasant in fact
when I was doing this I reminded me of
another Johnny Cash song if you haven't
heard this one I'm gonna really get very
frustrated because it's probably one of
his most famous songs and you can think
of this whenever you're writing C code
it burns burns burns the Ring of Fire
and that's kind of what programming and
see can be like it's a pleasant language
I personally prefer it over a language
like C++ but it is a very tedious and
very unforgiving domain so why couldn't
we write an LD preload in Python I mean
we have a tool like site on which takes
something that looks kind of like Python
code and compiles it to a C shared
object I mean when we create a Python py
module and we have scythe on co-pilot
that creates a dot C file which we can
then use a C compiler to turn into a
shared object and that Python
interpreter will happily dynamically
load a shared object this is how many of
the modules in a standard library work
modules like itertools many of the
modules are written in C they're not
compiled directly into your Python
binary or actually just shared objects
and scythe on gives you a way to do that
without having to write the C so why
can't we do this this would be a simple
you know shared object it's kind of ugly
looking this is scythe on Python so you
can see I had to pull out the DL SIM
function from DLF functions I wrote my
own malloc so you know every time my C
function calls or every time I see
program calls malloc I just print
something out why can't I do this well
it turns out you can't do it it's not
possible you can't write an LD preload
in Python dead stop because what'll
happen is scythe on will build this code
presuming that an interpreter is already
running your LD preload will try and
call this exposed C function which
presumes the Python interpreter is
running it'll start doing things
assuming that a Python interpreter has
been started where no Python interpreter
exists and no state has been set and
it'll seg fault on you almost
immediately you cannot write an LD
preload in Python except except it turns
out if you dig a little deeper one of
the themes I've noticed in some of the
talks I've given is you dig a little bit
deeper so I gave a talk last year in
previous year
about embedding Python interpreters
within themselves and I showed how you
can embed a Python one it's not a Python
- inside of Python 3 interpreter and the
trick to that was realizing that the
deal open call that many of us are
familiar with actually has a brother
named deal mopin with an eminent that is
very poorly documented that sits maybe a
couple lines down on the man page after
your eyes glaze over and you decide to
call it a night
well it turns out that you can't write
an LZ preload in Python but you can
wrote an LD audit in Python your dynamic
linker and I presume
quite literally your dynamic linker that
I know on most of the computers in this
room as long as you're not in Windows
because we'll just exclude them from the
conversation for the rest of the weekend
actually your dynamic linker allows you
to audit what that means is every time
your dynamic linker goes out and tries
to find a symbol it'll notify you of
what it's trying to do and it turns out
that one of the things that can notify
you is when it's trying to bind a symbol
so you can actually write an LD audit in
C and then C you can take you can try
and understand what these arguments are
you know the ref cook and the DEF cook
sounds very important as far as I can
tell the only thing that's really
important is sim and sim name for these
purposes but every time you try and bind
a symbol every time every time your
application tries to figure out where
was kill implemented where was malloc
implemented you can just get a
notification not only can you -
notification but you can step in and say
no don't use that one use this one over
here I'll say something kind of
interesting normally what you do when
interposing the or rather what you do
when doing a symbol binding is you just
return the symbol that was found so
somebody asked for malloc you look
around you say help Malick's over here
you give it to the program the program
uses malloc for the rest of its runtime
I won't go into the way the PLT works
there's a couple of other mechanics
involved there's some caching involved
there's this thing called the what is it
the GPT no it's called the global yeah
the G ot okay I can't remember the
acronym
and there's some mechanics there
involved but essentially when your
program tries to find a c function that
it doesn't implement itself it's
implemented a library it has to go
through the dynamic linker you can audit
that and have it give you notifications
what if instead of just returning the
symbol you embedded a Python interpreter
into LD audit and then you called out to
a Python module so every time your
dynamic linker tried to say where's
Malik where as free where's where's my
kill where's my door open where's my F
open where's my read where's my write a
little python interpreter there which we
just resolved that for you
in fact with just this one little piece
here you could end up writing your own
dynamic linker in Python and a Python
module well something really interesting
happens when you write about seven lines
of I take that as probably about ten
lines of C code to do this and this C
code doesn't really do anything very
interesting all I do is I look at a
module that's specified somewhere for a
function called resolve I take my symbol
name I do a little bit of mechanics that
are necessary in order to satisfy the
way that functions are called
in Python from the C layer and I just
call this function called resolve with
the symbol that I was looking for the
name of simul is looking for and what
would have been found otherwise and then
if it returned something that's not none
I just used that well then I can write a
really simple not quite Python but kind
of site on Python function called
resolve that just says if the symbol
name is open that's the call to sis call
that opens files on a system it returns
a file descriptor instead of returning
open return something else just store
what was originally resolved the real
open call and return my own function
called open now you can see that this
was very hairy and this is why I got no
sleep last night because why on earth is
that a long cast to avoid pointer cat
first we should already be in shock that
we have these weird angle brackets and
our Python code much less that these are
actually casts much less we're taking a
function pointer a casting to a
to avoid pointer and then to some CDF
type it's nuts and I don't know how I
found that incantation and I'm not sure
why that incantation works but just
trust me that's what you have to do it
turns out that things get much easier
from here because then what you can do
is you can just implement any C function
that you want in Python so here this is
just an implementation of your open call
every time a program tries to open a
file it has to call this this call open
that's the only interface that it has
for opening files it might call F open
which then eventually calls open there's
no other way that it can ask the kernel
to open a file well it can do m map and
things like that but explicitly for
opening a file the only way to do it is
with this open call well every time it
tries that my Python like Python code
just prints out what arguments are
passed it's kind of like s trace like a
really really wonky s trace the neat
thing here though is this is not quite
Python it's scythe on but it follows
kind of the same rules and I can program
it with the same I'd say convenience
that I can program normal Python so you
can see you know I'm just using advanced
string formatting I don't care what the
types are I'm not allocating any memory
this is actually what except for a
couple of small pieces like having the
the types here and having the CDF at the
front this is more or less very standard
Python well one interesting thing that I
could do is because that's really
boilerplate I could write a decorator
and the decorator I could just call it
preload and I could use the annotations
feature in Python 3 and I could just
write something that looked almost
exactly like pure Python that generated
the scythe unlike code built it and what
you end up with is you could take you
could write impure Python without any
knowledge of anything else
you can replace any c function in any
program anywhere now this this one this
was supposed to be the set piece of the
of the talk and when I presented it to a
couple of people late last night they I
felt they didn't quite get it and so I
had to come up with a compelling example
for them I'll show you an example you
know I like to find very trivially
simple solutions to common problems that
we have
so trivial that you look at that and you
say well hold on a second I can't really
tell there's something there but
suddenly all these mechanisms that I had
before I don't need so one thing that
you know I like to do is especially if
I'm deploying code I want to check new
code against old code I want to make
sure the results are the same and so one
thing that you might do is you might
check out the old code here and check
out the new code here but that can be
very clumsy another thing I might do is
I might add into my my program you know
some ability to say oh this is the new
modules is the old module just pull the
old function of the old module a new
function of the new module and compare
them well you know some of this
comparison and diffing mechanisms
already exists in the form of my version
control system get you know if I really
wanted to be very simple about that
every time I made a change to my code
I'd have one branch of my git repository
with the code as it stands and one
branch that I'm waiting to merge in with
all the changes that I want and I just
check out one of these branches over
here and check out one of the branches
over here and run my application in
parallel but I wouldn't do that because
it ends up being very clumsy and I have
a lot of physical artifacts and it's
kind of hard to script because if the
check out fails or if there's something
that has to be stashed you'll just kind
of blow up on me however one way that I
can get around physical artifacts is
there's a library called Lib get two and
I have no clue how to use Lib get - but
there's Python bindings for this this is
a common theme for me I find that I'm
just too lazy to learn enough C to
really write C I'd rather write Python
and even though PI get to which is just
a library for interacting with the git
repository has very similar API to Lib
get to when I'm playing with PI kit - I
can do Durer and help and I can kind of
[ __ ] my way around figuring out how to
use it whereas if I were writing this in
C I'd have to spend a lot of time and
man pages and documents and manuals and
it'd be very unforgiving so you can see
here's a simple example of what you can
do with Lib get to you can initialize a
repository you can get the head of the
repository and you can iterate through
all the elements all the objects all the
blobs all the files in that tree and you
can do that without checkouts without
any physical artifacts without shelling
out to the command line
what if I combine these two what if
instead of catting a file to my standard
out I could pass in my LD preload with a
commit hash and it would cat the file as
of that commit hash cat which doesn't
know anything about Python which doesn't
know anything about git is now get aware
right
I can I can make any program and how do
I do that well let's think about that
and you know I might simplify it and
this is how I actually simplified it you
have a little thing called get it and
you give it a commit hash and then any
program after that only sees the state
of the file system as of that good hash
and that shouldn't be too hard to do
actually because you can think that any
program that interacts with the file
system has to go through system calls
open close read/write stat the 64 bit
version of those you know a couple more
you'd have to spend a little bit of time
with man pages well it turns out you
don't have to spend a lot of time with
man pages probably bad on the order of
15 minutes per system call I tried this
because I had a little bit of down time
earlier and you can take any program
that was never designed to do anything
with git and just tell it every time you
try to open a file no no use my open
function over here that opens the file
via to get repository without any
physical artifacts one thing that I want
to do I didn't have time to do that I
expect will take about 30 minutes is I
want to write an LD audit and I'm not
writing any C code anymore by the way
I'm writing kind of C ish Python but
with my decorator I don't have to write
that the only thing I have to know is
the man page and what the are what the
original signature of the C function is
but outside of that I don't have to
write anything that doesn't look like
anything but Python well Python is a
really rich standard library I can
interact with zip files very easily from
Python why don't I just write a little
hook so every time you open a file if
it's a zip file
I just transparently unzip it suddenly
every single application on my computer
doesn't even doesn't even have to know
what a zip file is transparently can
read and write from zip files that's
kind of powerful isn't it
this is actually very similar to fuse
except instead of implementing a file
system in userspace
i've implemented something akin to a
file system in process space
and you can start to do some really neat
things I joked with one of my friends
who I show some of these things - but
he's a JavaScript guy and I said you
know you know what you can do with this
you never have to minify your JavaScript
to disk again just write a little a
little shim and your web server will
just minify it when it reads when it
opens you know every program you have
can minify it on open you never have to
store the minified javascript to disk
again you do some really weird things
here if anybody here remembers server
side includes from the old Apache days
now you could do something like that you
could have files that exist on disk in
one form and under certain processes
look in other ways automatically
generate themselves automatically
template themselves do a lot of really
neat things things which we could do
with fuse but would be very inconvenient
thing is you could do that with writing
only Python and in my experiments today
with a five minutes downtown here 10
minutes downtime here it is
exceptionally easy to write this in
Python so no doubt I don't I don't
expect to take more than 30 minutes for
me to write my zip file loader and then
every single program my LS my cat my
head my vim my OpenOffice my web browser
are now able to read and write two zip
files without even have to know their
zip files without even knowing anything
about what's going on because I've
interposed the system calls and because
the only way for them to interact with
the system is via their system calls and
I can do it very easily
because I can write it in Python and I
get nice error messages I don't get seg
fault all over the place you know I can
print things out I have to worry about
types or natori about memory allocation
sure I get a little bit of slowdown here
and there but the power is worth it so
that was the set piece for this talk and
I'll give you a small example I created
a really simple git repository there are
actually five commits in it now but
there are four commits I had a single
file and I changed it three times and so
you can do something just as simple as
this this is the file with this commit
hash I can cat the file with a different
commit hash I can cap the file with
another commit hash and you can see cat
has no clue that there is a git
repository there's no clue other than
there's files on disk that I'm opening
and reading from it's my little helper
there that's written in Python that is
now interest
affecting all of these system calls
Anderson with it so this is something
that I thought was kind of exciting I
hope that you can appreciate it and you
can see this is what the original file
has and if if you feel like you don't
quite understand it but it seems cool I
guess that's enough if you're not a fan
of Johnny Cash yet I have one more of
his most famous songs to share with you
before we conclude and you might ask me
why I did this and you might ask me why
I do any of these things and the reason
is I just do them for the sake of doing
them just like Johnny Cash when he was a
young boy his mom told him don't ever
play with guns just to watch him die
although sometimes I must admit when I
hear that whistle blowing I hang my head
and ride
so that's Python and Johnny Cash a
little bit of subversive Python I hope
you enjoyed it I'm James Barr I think
we're finished a bit early so if anyone
has any questions who like who once
listened a little bit more Johnny Cash
oh yeah you know the interesting thing
is if I don't want this video on YouTube
I'll play more than seven seconds of any
of these songs because they'll
automatically block it so I should be a
little bit more careful than that right
any questions any thoughts it's very
interesting technique when I first
discovered it I thought this couldn't be
useful at all but now I'm realizing that
you could do a lot of really absurd
things with it
with Python is is so that I think the
Python element is though is the so III
think the Python dimensional what makes
it most impressive being able to
intercept calls Windows has their own
mechanisms like detours for doing things
like this but Bane will do it
conveniently and being able to turn
around like an LD preload in 30 minutes
to an hour is it's quite amazing
oh that's fantastic
oh that's amazing that's fantastic
that's what they so so
maybe I should give a I'll show you some
what maybe I'll go to lightning talk
tomorrow show you some wild stuff I'll
show you some well stuff that you can do
Python is a very permissive language so
what one thing I've always wanted to do
is um you can think that Python is used
for very big systems and sometimes in
those systems you have memory that you
don't really want people to be poking
around you can do things like lock
memory pages so they don't get paged to
disk what I want to do for a long time
is create a type constructor that you
that can wrap any type to make sure that
type never gets paid to disk so then you
can create your own custom password type
and you'd never never get pasted the
disk which in some applications would
actually be a legitimate security
concern that if these secure credentials
never get paid to disk then we lose so
so I don't I think that there's the the
the I think there's a problem because
sandbox in Python is very difficult
thing to do I have my approach for
sandboxing Python and my approach for
sandboxing Python I patched the see eval
loop the main interpreter loop so every
time you try and push an element to the
stack that you're not supposed to look
at it blows you up and for the most part
I can't figure out any ways around that
it also allows you to is anyone seen
that one that one's really neat you want
to see that one let's see if I have if I
have a working version of it what was it
called read watches
Python okay
do I have internet access Python 3
let's pip install it 3 pip pip 3
if you wanted to if you wanted to let me
stick this in my anaconda Python maybe
three installments okay there we go
let's see if this builds this one was
really neat ah fail but I've failed
because it's a not the right version of
Python maybe I can I need a Python with
pip
does have pip yes this has pip pip
install do just this one was a really
triple three
no that one failed unfortunately I just
showed in the lightning talk but I have
this thing called read watches where you
can where you can intercept things where
they're pushed and popped to the Python
stack do all sorts of really really wild
stuff with that you can implement
pointers in Python you can do Sam boxing
in Python you can do lazy loading of
Python you can really really wreck the
way the interpreter works and you can
the the reason for that was and actually
the initial intention of this talk was
going to show you how you can use some
of these patches and a C Python
interpreter to implement better
debuggers I think that some of these
some of the crazier patches that you
might have are things which you might
not feel comfortable being able to get
right in production and so you might
wonder should I really do this if I
can't get it done perfectly however I
think there's in the course of our work
there's often some area where we have a
lot of flexibility in terms of the
correctness of the solutions we have
often that's in a design phase or a
debugging phase and so one thing that
I've want to do for a very long time is
collect a bunch of patches to a c python
interpreter then allow you a couple more
hooks solely for debugging purposes read
watches would be one of those and so
what you could do is you could tag a
variable so that anytime that variable
was looked at or anytime that object was
looked at it would trigger a callback
and you could figure out if you had some
large data pipeline with millions of
objects but one of them was malformed in
some way where it was being caught along
the line this is similar to what you
have in a language like in gdb with read
watches as well that's something that
what you cannot currently do in Python
and you can do some really nice
debugging you could have debugging on
par with what you can do you can do
things like if any here anybody here's a
user of PD b PB is so limited because
it's designed for a very static form of
debugging that's appropriate in c or c++
which is not appropriate in python so
how do you put a breakpoint on the
lambda in pd be kind of breaks on you
well you could use read watches to put
break points on lambdas which is a very
reasonable and desirable thing to do any
questions did anyone have any idea what
I was talking about the whole time
Oh
except except when I was talking about
Johnny Cash very good well I don't want
to keep you folks any longer I hope
you've enjoyed this amazing day at pi
that I hope to see you all tomorrow
maybe I'll give a lightning talk if I
can find a version of the code where the
read watches work otherwise please enjoy
your afternoon I think we're going to
the pub in about 15 minutes if you like
this talk I'd love to chat with you more
if you do any of this stuff if you get
paid money doing this stuff I'd love to
talk to you because I actually think
that there's some real legitimate
business value here it's just that it's
difficult to find organizations that
have the shall we say the stomach for it
thank you so much